[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well he's sam monson uh pro football
focus lead
nfl analyst sam good morning thanks for
joining us let me start with that
question
the hall of fame it feels like is based
off of
the feelings we have for these players
when the writers get together and they
nominate somebody they're very
passionate about it
you deal with analytics just the
analytical part of this
with philip rivers is he a first ballot
hall of famer
i think it's tough because you're
comparing him to the guys from
bygone eras for whom we don't really
have all that data i mean one of the
great things about pff whether you agree
with our numbers or you disagree with
them is we have the grading
on every single player on every single
play since we started doing this
back in 2006 so we can at least try and
compare these guys like for like
but it gets really hard when you start
trying to say all right phillip rivers
just passed dan marino on the all-time
passing yards list but i don't think
there's anybody out there that saw both
those guys play
that would say philip rivers is a better
quarterback than dan marino
um dan marino was obviously a hall of
famer and no one
would argue that but because of this
explosion and passing and how much
easier it is to
to play quarterback in today's nfl how
all these guys are now at the top of the
all-time lists
does that put philip rivers in i don't
know who's more of a first ballot hall
of famer frank gore or philip rivers
i think phillip rivers i think frank
gore's legacy
is this insane durability that
really is remarkable when you look at
what he was as a prospect
like he he dropped in the draft because
people were concerned that he'd had
multiple knee surgeries and that he
wouldn't last in the nfl
and then the defining characteristic of
frank gore's there's nothing that can
knock this guy out of the league
and he just keeps on trucking well the
same thing with phillip rivers he hasn't
missed a game
true true but i think phillip rivers
peaks have been higher than frank gore's
i think you can make the case
that philip rivers has been genuinely
one of the best quarterbacks
over the past you know over his entire
career i i don't know that you can
really make that case for frank gore
outside of a season or two if you were
going to redraft
this first round i saw where you looked
at the first round
and went back and looked at how these
rookies are performing
would is there somebody that stands out
that this that they would have changed
the draft
that they would have gone either higher
or lower based uh after
uh eight games that where how they
performed where they were drafted
i think minnesota's justin jefferson
would definitely be higher up the list
than he is now
he might be the first receiver off the
board if we had a chance to redo all
this
um all again all of his concerns we were
looking at him as a college prospect as
well
he did incredibly from the slot but can
he play outside excuse me can he play
outside
when he has to deal with press coverage
can he still get off the line can he
still do all that savvy outrunning stuff
the answer is overwhelmingly yes and
that just immediately puts you further
up the draft because
you're a more impactful player when you
can play outside and deal with the press
coverage
at the nfl level he's been an absolute
superstar wide receiver and i think
very much the the match of any of those
top first round guys
highest grade you've given to a rookie
this year's who
um i think right now it's actually
michael owen the the
new england patriots i guess utility
offensive lineman because he's played
three different positions and done them
all well but this was not
a highly touted draft pick he's just
come in and been an absolute force
particularly in the run game
and filled him wherever they've need him
whether it's right tackle whether it's
the guard position
and really been phenomenal i mean you
know i've seen people say that if this
guy was a first rounder we'd be talking
about how new england's draft was
fantastic because they snagged
this pro bowl all-pro caliber player
right at the top of the draft but
because he's a you know a lower round
guy
it's kind of passing almost unnoticed
higher grade for joe burrow or
justin herbert it's funny because
they're in
almost exactly the same spot they're
really tight together in terms of
grading but the grade comes about in
almost completely
opposite ways joe burrow has been
incredibly consistent
particularly up to the sort of deep uh
big shots anything below 20 yards he's
been absolute money
um and has been doing it in in the face
of incredible pressure in cincinnati
justin herbert is like the king of the
volatile stats so whether it's third
down play whether it's
deep throws down the field whether it's
you know all those big time throws and
those kinds of things the pff charts
he's been phenomenal at those things
but has missed more regular easy throws
missed more of the
the kind of consistently easy stuff than
joe burrow has and he's been dealing
with pressure as well
and it kind of nets out to almost the
exact same pff grade overall
what about clyde edwards hillaire his
grade in where he probably should have
been taken
even though he has a running back yeah
and that's really the thing is
you know pff is in this analytics group
that would say look just don't take a
running back in the first round it's not
that they won't ever look good it's that
they just won't justify
that draft slot you could get him later
on the draft or get a comparable player
later on the draft and you'd see the
same kind of production
and i think that's kind of what we're
seeing from clyde edwards hilaire his
grade is okay he's had good games but
really what we're seeing is this product
of
the kansas city offense and when that
thing is ticking along
when it's going great when mahomes is
playing out of his mind and pat
and andy reid is scheming up all these
plays clyde edward solaire is a good
player to have on the receiving end of
those
catches out of the backfield and and be
taking the carries
but when things don't go as well he has
those worse games and just doesn't look
as good running backs
are basically a product of their their
environment uh within the offense
he's sam monson pro football focus lead
nfl analyst who do you consider the best
running back in the nfl
i think right now it's dalvin cook um
again
what i just said running backs are by
and large a product of their environment
he's the one
guy this season that isn't i mean he
he's been
massively over performing what the
vikings have been giving him in terms of
you know yards he has by far i think the
most yards
after contact in the nfl and only
himself and derek henry have more total
yards than dalvin cook has yards after
contact he's just consistently
generating an incredible amount of
yardage off his own back beyond
what is being blocked for we brought
this up a couple of days ago i
asked the audience you could have any
wide receiver for the next five years
who do you think they picked dk yes
yeah did his slippage in the draft
and his profile was it just based off he
looks like he should be
great but he's always injured is that
what it boiled down to
no i think there were legitimate
concerns about his
change of direction skills um he had he
went to the combine and posted
this three cone time that was slower
than tom brady it was you know
historically bad
um and he he fixed it a little bit at
his pro day like he got faster
the the one at the combine he slipped a
little bit and they don't let you take
it again
so it was a bad time there he improved
it at his
pro day but it still wasn't good it was
still a concern as was his 20 shuttle
times anything that was trying to
measure
change of direction he was really bad at
and i think that
leads you to think well okay does that
limit him at the next level to just
being this
linear vertical threat guy who can't
really run the entire route tree
even considering that i think most draft
analysts had him going higher than he
went in the draft it was still
a shock to see him slip as far as he did
but i think there were
real concerns about you know a missing
component to his game that just
has been changed that aren't that isn't
the missing component anymore when does
pro football focus do a deep dive into
trevor lawrence and justin fields
i mean we've got guys cranking on that
right now we do uh we grade every
college game as well so we've got grades
on all of these guys mike
renner is our big uh draft guy he's been
the guy grinding on that every single
game of those guys careers
um so i don't know if we have a a
specific deep dive article up on the
site
but we've definitely got data on all
those guys right now are they working in
that room behind that door behind you
yeah that's a room that goes downstairs
into a basement where there's just one
little light hanging out of the ceiling
that's where we put all the analysts
worst starting quarterback in the nfl is
who
the worst starting quarterback i mean i
think you can say it was dwayne haskins
before he lost his job
now it's it's going to be a battle
between you know sam darnold in new york
drew lock in denver it hasn't shown
enough really to get out of that
conversation it's it's those kind of
young guys
that have disappointed in bad situations
so far
and i thought this was drew locke's
coming out party and they had weapons
and here we go with drew lock i know he
got injured but
it feels like sam that the window of
opportunity
is about two years like baker mayfield's
in his third year and it feels like he's
playing for his future in cleveland
are you guys getting the sense of how
long that window is for a
quarterback to prove himself i think you
know this run of quarterbacks that have
been successful right away have
definitely changed
the opinion of how long you get and if
you don't show something
almost right away you have to fight
pretty hard for that job
particularly if you're not a top pick
you know if you're a first your number
one overall pick you get a little bit
more
time to to show something but if you're
not you know you get a year or two
and then we got to move on it's it's
time to find the next guy because it's
not
the landscape is different to the way it
was a decade ago you're not in a spot
anymore where you have to give alex
smith 100 million dollar contract
because the prospect of not having alex
smith
is so terrifying you can find those guys
pretty easily now and so teams are much
more emboldened to
say all right this guy is not a hall of
famer he's not the next
all-pro we need we're gonna cut bait and
move on to the next guy
do you remember when we sort of took a
player for granted
the way we do patrick mahomes and and
and this feels like the embryonic stages
of michael jordan's greatness
when he had team success prior to that
he was sort of just a highlight reel
phenomenon
then they started winning and it felt
like we got bored with the story
and then carl malone won an mvp and
charles barkley won an mvp
i don't are we at that stage with
patrick mahomes where and i know russell
has played
extremely well but are we at the point
where we're taking
uh patrick mahomes for granted and i'll
give you
one in the nfl as well i think we've
already passed that point with aaron
donald
i think you know aaron donald should
have won every defensive player of the
year award
since his rookie season so not the
rookie season but everyone since then
should have gone to aaron donald
and they haven't because we've just
gotten bored giving the award to aaron
donald who is by
far and away the best defensive player
in the nfl i think he's the best player
now how do you how do you gauge that
though sam i
i mean to me it's how much further ahead
is he than the rest of his peers at his
position right so it's it's really hard
to compare positions to say
the best defensive lineman in the nfl is
better than the best linebacker is
better than the best safety the best
receiver
so let's just stick to his position
group and say
how much better is he than fletcher cox
or
chris jones or whoever else the next
interior guy is and i think it's light
years ahead of those guys when you
consider
how much more pressure he gets how much
more pressure he gets on a rate basis
um and how much more he's double team
than some of those guys and still doing
that
it's absolutely unbelievable and just in
terms of pff grading
you know the top x seasons in terms of
pff grades on the interior have all been
aaron donald it's just a list of aaron
donald seasons
that vary slightly so i think you're
right though i think mahomes is reaching
that category where
you need to watch him again to remind
yourself that like this isn't normal
most quarterbacks don't do this and we
should remember that this guy is a
singularly unique talent otherwise we
will get bored with him the same way we
do
with aaron donald sam good to talk to
you enjoy the weekend
thank you very much thank you sam monson
pro football focus lead
nfl analyst